Danny Roden he wants to know is modern
human nature completely shaped by
culture and society or by biology and
evolution I have pretty strong feelings
that right now the differences that we
see among humans on the entire planet
are due to culture and society biology
and evolution and in other words genetic
differences between people around the
world are responsible for almost none of
the differences that we observe amongst
people and there's a really interesting
chapter about this in a book I recently
recommended called lessons of history by
will and Ariel Durant Durant Durant
Durant Durant and it points to how a lot
of racist ideologies are based on the
pretext that there are important
differences in terms of the genetics of
individuals when it comes to everything
from intelligence to whatever else and
the reality is that the genetic
differences between all humans are so
incredibly minor and just because two
people might look very different doesn't
mean that their DNA is fundamentally
very different and I think that the
overwhelming difference over the lap for
humans really over the last many
thousands of years have been due to a
culture and society not to biology
evolution or so-called genetic
differences right and even approaching
this question when it came down to
biology and evolution I didn't even
consider differences between races as
part of that because of course at the
end of the day we're all Homo sapiens
right and I think culture and
civilization are far more important in
what makes us human but those are also a
defect of the fact that we have big
brains the fact that we're able to walk
upright for most of what I've read and
there could be I don't actually know
like with climate change I know sort of
what's the 99% opinion and what's the 1%
opinion I don't actually know if what
I'm about to say is the 99% opinion or
the 90% opinion or 80% but from
everything I've read there have been no
significant biological changes to humans
over the last 10
and years that would account for the
differences that we see that it's been
culture and society and of course
medical advancements have had
significant impacts impacts upon how how
people live and how people age in
longevity and that type of thing but
that's my understanding and I don't
believe that it's controversial to say
that although maybe people will email me
and they'll say no David there have been
significant biological changes over the
last 10,000 years well if people take
issue with you eating french fries in
Belgium they'll certainly take issue
with this yeah yeah I don't know it was
a good point yet I mean that I think
you've said it all yes yeah I'm sure
someone is going to take issue with what
I said but so to answer the question oh
yeah well the good thing about you know
culture and civilization are inherent to
humans I mean I'm sure you can even
point out some examples of other members
of the animal kingdom doing similar
things but we've always associated that
as something that's inherently human
yeah absolutely
inherent one of the when people talk
about what makes humans human one of the
key things that's a really interesting
thing is humans have the ability to
think about the future in a way that
most animals don't most animals are able
to sort of plan for what they're doing
right now
am i hunting prey right now am i seeking
shelter right now and obviously you know
we have bees who make hives and it's
sort of a planning for the future but it
got a bunch of acorns but a lot of that
stuff appears to be more instinctual
than anything else and so the ability of
humans to plan for the future in the way
that we do is a pretty interesting
difference for most animals we're so
smart David yeah it's very nice are you
okay Danny good question I think we
probably messed up the answer pretty
badly but that's okay we're doing it
we're taking it as it comes
we've got a great bonus show planned for
you today